i just want to pose with you
i love you you look good i love this
whole vibe oh thank you this is pamela
roland yes and um i'm styled by danny
and uh emma
and it's just i'm just really happy to
be here you know it feels great this
feels like okay
pose is officially over this is the last
thing that we're really doing
we got to see i got to see my sisters
they're right down there so you know
it's just an amazing time and i'm just
really excited to be here and happy yeah
are you guys going to celebrate it all
tonight or just spend time together
well we are going to try our best to
spend time but you know what when you
pray for something and you get it you
are blessed and you know i will share
this with you the last time i was here
at the critics choice awards i came in
feeling
dismayed because at that moment in time
i was going through a divorce and i was
told that day the very day of the
critics choice awards that i could lose
my life
and um because of domestic violence
and
i showed up and it was here at the
critics choice awards that brad simpson
and fx got together and really helped me
and made me feel so comfortable i
started an entirely new life i have a
new fiance who is amazing to know what
love is like and to feel it feels
amazing so standing on this carpet today
is a part of my life where
i survived i conquered i found
everything that i needed for me so this
is celebration for me for my sisters for
us all oh you brought me to you
that is beautiful and you are so
inspiring and that was so special thank
you for sharing that with me
oh my goodness
last question who is your biggest critic
critics choice awards
um i am my biggest critic yes i i think
i am because i just
i just feel like when you have to fight
so hard for life you have to try to be
as perfect as possible when you go
forward people have to know that
undeniab that they can't deny you you
are undeniable so that takes a lot of
hard work so i do criticize myself very
harshly
well you look fantastic and i'm so happy
for you
yes you better win we gotta win we
always win